good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day it is
wednesday hope everyone is having a
great week so far
i am so exhausted i spent the morning
just climaxing with theo
and we are all humped out
wow
and is dude could he make it into the
studio today to celebrate this glorious
occasion no theo is actually booked and
busy
today i'm doing a partnership
with amazon pups they have like you know
so much good [ __ ] at amazon this is not
sponsored i mean i'm going to be doing
sponsor content but this particular
segment is not sponsored um and they're
literally throwing theo a party so he's
like getting ready he's relaxing he like
the event is going to be they have like
a ball throwing station treat station
like he it's literally his bark mitzvah
and he's just preparing and he didn't
want to invite his auntie or his best
friend bruce
uh would his best friend bruce fly in
for his bark mitzvah one thousand
percent um hosting a party
yeah no um
he is bruce loves a party
bruce does love a party i'm gonna see if
magnolia can make it
oh she probably can't but she'll
appreciate the invitation yeah i'm all
about last-minute invitations margo if
you're watching this text me
uh okay well that's really exciting theo
news that i didn't expect for today that
he's throwing himself a soiree it's
gonna be the event of the season
no lie i'm sure it is will the hundreds
of other pop stars butters gonna come
mystery anyone i didn't invite anyone
from the dog walking crew because theo
very much likes to keep like his camp
friends and his school friends separate
um but there will be plenty of dogs
there we had like a call about it
yesterday um
they were telling me like the down low
on the event and it's literally dog
central theo's so [ __ ] excited are
they famous dogs or nobodies so it's
like definitely like a media influencer
event so some of the dogs are famous and
some of the dog's owners are like
influencers and content creators got it
and do you think any are like you and
theo that where you're both famous
we are a unique blend i don't know
there's not many like us no there's real
no i guess a lot of influencers have
made their dogs
part of their shtick not as much as we
have not as much as we have like these
two have their own podcast let me um let
me ask you something do i look any
different
did you get a haircut i did
yesterday wow that feels like forever
ago i know
i got a haircut yesterday i cut three
inches and i know everyone's like and i
hate to be like pick me kendall jenner
energy but like it feels so short but
like i had to do it you don't understand
how like when i get off of stage i have
to literally shave the back of my neck
because it's in it like it's in just one
big knot my hair was just like so heavy
and it was making me like so sweaty and
i feel so much lighter my hair took me
like half the time today so it's just
like these are the sacrifices we make
for beauty
and it looks the same
wow
i don't know what's worse like being
told like i spent all this money to look
the same or being like oh it's so
different because either one of them
will trigger me
right so i guess i'm just going to go
with honesty yeah that's always the best
policy you look great
because it's like a little more bounce
okay grows back i try not to get too
attached when i'm getting a haircut
because like it'll be back for sure but
like when you're a girly who's like best
feature is best and only feature is her
hair
um you put a lot of stock into it
especially when you use your hair
obviously as
hair but you use it also as like a
security blanket a chin cover
like there's a lot of
there's a lot riding on my hair but do
you think that now that you're the
snatcher
there was less pressure for this haircut
no
i'm still like deeply attached to my
hair and i have been since seriously the
seventh grade
you should get a bob
well what did i say i would get about oh
if uh brandon frazier doesn't at least
get nominated for an oscar i will be
getting a bob even though i feel like i
have a bob right now
no my hair is grossly long right now i'm
getting a haircut next week i'm so
excited you don't have like a new hair
girly in florida do you you're waiting
till you come back to new york yeah no i
haven't even embarked on looking for
someone yet i don't cut my hair often
enough that i really need to i maybe do
twice a year so like i'll be in new york
twice a year
one last thing i have to do down here
you know what i did have to do yesterday
i'm trying to get my learner's permit
and down here you have to take a
four-hour drug and alcohol course about
the dangers of drunk driving
and
i'm shook to the core like they make you
like you have to read all this stuff and
you have to sit there for four hours you
can't get to the next part yeah until
you've gone through until you spent
enough time with each segment yeah and
this is compelling stuff they're all
like so [ __ ] mean and shady about
like people who just drink in general as
they should they're like even the
dullest person
like wouldn't want to put like a toxin
into their body and call that fun well
you know like a girl i'm actually
so here for this
course i think um a lot of people need
to take it including sam hunt
um
who else just got tiffany haddish
bella hadid who else like literally
every celebrity on the planet
um
but
we had to i had to do one of those like
before going to college and they like
it's like timed and they make you sit
they know if you don't actually do the
the little quiz
it is [ __ ] torture and you know what
it's so torturous it kind of makes me
want to drink a drive
just despite the state you know just
despite the college board it was so
terrifying good and
honestly i'm scared straight not that i
had any desire
i don't really drink it i don't really
drive right
i i don't think i will ever like it's so
scary and even they're talking about
like one drink how it impairs your
judgment you guys if you are someone who
thinks that they can drink and drive
like
don't do it
no by the way like obviously getting
drunk and driving is a big no-no but i
feel like a lot of people will be like i
only had one glass of wine i'm totally
fine to drive and people think i'm such
a narc but like i will not like just
uber like what's the big deal like even
one drink it impairs like your reaction
it delays your reaction time down to
just even if it's a second or two off
which doesn't seem like a lot but it's
it could that's all it takes in a car
crash life and death yeah and also they
were showing us all these cases of drunk
drivers who got in accidents and like
the drivers are fine the drugs yeah
the other people died and the drivers
are now in jail like this 20 year old
cheerleader she killed a pedestrian and
now she's like and now i'm in jail
yeah no by the way um
that i feel like is more often than not
what happens like because you're the one
driving recklessly like using other
people as
collateral
yeah so it was not to start off the show
on such a dark note but like i just feel
like everyone needs to be reminded about
the dangers of drunk driving 100
especially if you're going to be driving
like me one day
god willing
god willing i did schedule my permit
test
it's not for a few weeks because that
was the first available point have you
started practicing
no we i have to finish this course and
then i'll start my
practice exams here let me do a test
question for you
okay when the light is red what do you
do well we haven't learned that yet
you stop
very good even though the questions are
low-key hard on that test
it's like who yields when the elder
needs to yield yeah
and they deadass makeup scenarios that
literally never happened to you when
you're driving no or it's like scenarios
that are so
uh
remote like there are certain symbols
that you probably will never see if you
don't ever in like certain parts of the
country like icy bridge or whatever
right and they're like what does that
mean you know what that like those
obscure road signs remind me of what i
wonder if you know what i'm gonna say
the most iconic film of all time that i
reference here probably once a year it's
not one of my let go two references but
we do a segment on it at least once a
year
i'm listening
come on you don't know what i'm talking
about does anyone have seen it i think
so is it uh like the children
that movie made us watch for toast movie
no it's a comedy it's so funny about a
family road trip oh rv yes if you guys
have never seen rv
it is robin williams best work also it's
just like a weirdly star-studded cast
the daughter is played by jojo get out
leave right now she sings route 66 at
the end uh the mom is played by like the
most annoying mom like wife character
from curb your enthusiasm what's her
name cheryl cheryl
i was going to say that too but now i'm
thinking that's a different girl
no it's the blonde girly yeah yeah it's
so funny like you will audibly cackle
cackle it's not my favorite family road
trip movie
what is we're the millers
you know i walked out of the theater i
love that movie
by the way that's like a
generally beloved film
it's really it holds up 100
so anyways don't drink and drive
especially if you're going on a road
trip but especially for anything
don't do it
don't
and yeah
now i'm going to have that same energy
that you have about it i've been scared
good good i've been scared straight
sorry i forgot like the one thing i
wanted to come on here and say is after
you berated me endlessly i finally
watched untold the man taitea story
um
and at first i think maybe you like
hyped it up like a little too much about
how like depressing it was because i was
like no this is definitely sad
but i wasn't like bereft you know left
on the side of the road clutching my
pearls
however towards the end i was so bereft
i was on the side of the road clutching
my pearls i was so upset
and so angry
um
and i actually shed a tear um just like
at that final moment so much of the
documentary was about reneda who was
clearly an unwell person
um and i wasn't really interested at all
in hearing what they had to say like
their reasoning you know their
motivation uh the delusion thinking that
uh they were helpful in winning football
games from across you know a cell phone
however um
and so i thought like we were going to
get like more
is it reneta renaija renai sorry i
thought we were going to get more renai
like content towards the end and like
maybe they wanted us to feel bad for
them
i did not
for one moment feel bad i felt bad for
manti having to listen to renae's music
and then post about it on his twitter
that's what i felt bad for but i did not
feel bad one iota for renaissance
renaissance clearly
unwell
really unwell and
i didn't even feel like renaija learned
her lesson like i didn't really feel the
true remorse and then when mentai was
like i forgive renai i'm like manti like
you don't have to it's fine we don't
forgive her we don't i never would i
never could like this just came into
your life and for no reason from you and
no and stole everything that you've
worked your whole life for and for no
reason other than their own selfish
gains yeah
wait and then also it made me think
because like when the end i think what
really got to him like wasn't even so
much of the loss of potential was just
the way he was like endlessly mocked by
the world when he's clearly someone who
comes from a family with like a lot of
respect for themselves and he had a lot
of respect and they respected faith and
hard work and like all like the decent
pillars of humanity
and then just to become a joke i think
he was so upset by how that affected his
family um
and i thought that was interesting that
that's what he kind of was left with
and it made me think
not that they're at all similar but like
there were a lot of people who believed
that manti was in on the hoax and let's
just and he wasn't but let's just say
for argument's sake that he was
he still didn't deserve you know matt
the cartoons made about him the memes
made like it was horrible like the way
you would have thought he was a murderer
like that's that's what yeah that's how
you treat murderers
and it just made me think of
the story we spoke about yesterday about
that girl sumner stroh who is like out
here um making videos about adam levine
and like on tick tock she's being mocked
endlessly and like don't get me wrong
like have i been like laughing at some
of the content yes um but it's just like
the way like the entire internet will
galvanize against a person whether
they're in the wrong or not like is so
mean and it's so unethical and like that
type of [ __ ] and that type of treatment
is like really what makes people
suicidal like it's not okay
yeah not that the two situations are
even remotely similar it was just on my
mind because we had spoken about it
yesterday and like at the end of the day
whatever you think about the affair like
this is just a girl like she's a girl in
la like she's 25 years old like just
give a break
yeah well you know we'll talk about that
story today so uh that's would be
interesting if your perspective has
changed i mean in this documentary if
i'm like
giving my opinion on the situation of
like married men my opinion hasn't
changed but just on the internet's
reaction to it
that
has changed but let me just really
quickly go back to the man tita thing i
thought that the guys from dead spin and
i don't really know much about dead spin
i just know that they're like they give
like gawker energy
yeah i think they might have been owned
by gawker at one time because they use
like the same font but i really felt
like the two guys who they had in the
documentary who are responsible for
uncovering the hoax like weren't coming
at manti from a bad place and they were
even surprised how it went so negative
and what the [ __ ] was with all the
homophobia like that was [ __ ] random
yeah
and like i kind of loved the documentary
like putting all these
still popular and relevant
news media people from all these
different channels like putting them on
blast and like they're being low-key
[ __ ] homophobic like first of all
what's with the jump to gay
i hate when people like use sexuality
like as an insult like
and like it's they they think some they
thought at the time that manti did
something like crazy for and like
thirsty for attention so like why you
gotta be gay like wha why is that your
logical next step and like jump to
conclusion is homosexuality like the
whole thing just had like a really kind
it's because renae was a man
that's why like
i thought it was because like oh he was
pretending to have a girlfriend so he
must be gay no i think it was like he
was pretending this was a girlfriend but
it was really a boyfriend and he knew
oh i think that's okay well that's a
little bit more logical but still it
doesn't justify like
even openly gay they had anderson cooper
on there like it's like sexuality is
something that's supposed to be
protected like and you're not supposed
to out someone like it was just the
whole thing felt so [ __ ] icky yeah
it's so crazy when you watch back
documentaries and this one is pretty
recent history yeah and how the media
gets stuff so wrong and it just makes
you wonder like what they're getting
wrong today now it's not like they've
changed like it's the same people okay
so they wouldn't do that interview with
britney spears the way they did it then
like that they are not making like the
exact same mirror image errors but
it's always the media like being nasty
it's so true like all these
documentaries years later also um the
moment that really got to me that like
choked me the [ __ ] up was his interview
on katie couric um
where his parents like sat down and it
was just like these are just like normal
good people who are like
their whole lives like they just you
know they love their community and they
love their church and like they did
everything right and so did he like he
was really like a pillar in his
community even when he went to notre
dame and he was like a fish out of water
and he still like rose to the occasion
he's just like a good good person
and
it's not like he did anything
let's do anything wrong you know and
then this just happened to him no and
then like the thing that really upset me
was like he was just getting dragged and
people weren't believing him because he
had a girlfriend for three years that he
didn't meet which like is like a weird
thing to do
um
and so he was then put on blast for like
kind of being weird you know what i mean
and that's like embarrassing there were
just so many levels and the thing i was
not expecting was dr phil uh the way i
would take a bullet for dr phil i think
he's the most precious gem of a man and
at the end of the day like it all comes
back to dr phil you know he cracked the
case wide open he did like when he got
renaija to do her like female voice i
was shook because i was also thinking
i'm like who the [ __ ] is leaving these
voicemails but there was two things that
really confused me
the first was the girl who actually was
in the photos as lanaya her name was
like diane or something
when the mantis taiyo story broke of
like him losing his girlfriend and his
grandmother on the same day they had
pictures of the girlfriend dead spin was
pulling those pictures like did that
girl not see that and be like hey i'm
alive i had the same question
and then the second thing was like under
i need to know more about like under
what circumstances she sent that photo
with like the red
writing on the piece of paper and like
the gang sign
when he got that photo i was like what
the [ __ ] like maya must be
you know photoshop wizard photoshop face
tune queen yeah but then when diane
explained how it came through it made
sense like people do stuff like that on
the internet like we're trying to get
like you know we're making a collage for
my friend who's just sick and we want
everyone's picture like saying get well
soon and then renee could write whatever
she wanted on there yeah
and like honestly it's pretty [ __ ]
genius
no it was so crazy like the whole i just
i just love manti like you know what i
want to know
who sent that first tip to dead spin
yes
yes i mean people were talking about it
there was like a few tweets like it
might have been people in the community
maybe back in hawaii like yeah there
were like people who knew about it i
don't know how and that's a really good
call as well i thought that person was
going to sit down in the documentary too
yeah
um it was really upsetting and i was
happy to then go on a manti teo rabbit
hall find that he is married he is a
child he has found happiness he ended up
making about 10 million dollars in the
nfl which is obviously a lot of money
but that literally would have been his
first year salary if he had been picked
as he should have been picked um and
honestly you know i'm like a san
francisco 49ers stan
juice check however there is a special
place in my heart for the san diego
chargers because they picked him up i
know
and i think it might be the san diego
chargers time honestly the chargers the
chargers
i'm a chargers fan you know now because
it's got used to charging on your ipad
instead of mine
dead of mine
now that i've moved not that i ever had
really allegiances to football teams
well i guess we're cowboys family
actually but um i guess like if we're
thinking like that we're like a new york
giants family you are
you're from new york too [ __ ] no no but
like my family not you
like you're my family wow i'm not a
member of your family like me exactly
most of florida disowns her sister wow
jackie wow
me zach harry and brew are cowboys
family so you don't consider me a part
of you zach harry and brew
oh
that's an interesting question no i
would just lay my life out on the line
for any member of your family but okay
okay
so
it's so good to know where we stand it's
so good i'm glad to be a cowboys fan the
more you know i'll have to tell more you
know i have to tell ben
who does ben root for
um whoever's like in his dms you know
100
like whoever follows him like i know
there's like a guy from wisconsin green
bay who like ben is friends with i think
they play golf together and they like
message all the time it's the same way
like but i think you know us becoming a
part of the juice check family like that
through a wrench in ben's plans i think
we're gonna have to go out to san
francisco
for a game like i'm like the way i'm
such a 49ers fan
it's not normal
yeah i was gonna say like now sometimes
i'm watching tv i'm like am i supposed
to be a dolphins fan or a bucks fan
no
i think uh
i don't really
i think you i think when it comes to
football you don't bloom where you're
planted
got it but you bloom where you're born
some of the other sports are like open
for interpretation because like zach
doesn't have a hockey team that he
really
cares we're so i think we're panthers
fans
um the panthers did invite us to a game
and they brought a teddy bear they gave
like some merch so i think maybe i see
that for you however um the thing about
being a new york sports fan which i'm
not but like i keep up it's like it's
riddled with embarrassment you know like
the knicks embarrassing the jets like
kill me now
the one kind of cool thing about new
york sports is the rangers like they are
good they've always been good they
always will be good the games are like
social outings like celebrities always
go so like if i were you i would stick
with the rangers and like i have like
fond memories of going to rangers games
as a child with our now deceased father
watching your mirror yogurt so when i go
to rangers games like i'm always
cheering for your mirror yogurt even
though i believe he retired about 15
years ago i'm always cheering for wayne
gretzky
who's that he's a famous ranger
right see like rangers are like there's
cloud there is cloud okay you're right
i'll stick with the rangers and
the marlins
baseball yeah
but also we have the yankees and the
mats though those are both good too
yeah it's just you know things change
when you move this is literally like the
morning goal like we're so athletic
we're so athletic anyways all i'm saying
is that my allegiances are up for grabs
okay well now that's so cool
now that football has started you know
we always like to put in our predictions
for the super bowl oh yeah
um
oh yeah
uh i think we should do it
okay
you give a team was last year the 49ers
against the bucks
or the chiefs no am i just making all
that up
i feel like
kyle juice check was in the super bowl
what uh no is the bengals oh i should
know this harry potter bangles
ugh okay like honestly i'm so done with
the rams like
i have like and maybe it's just jealousy
but like i hate everyone who goes to
rabbids games i hate everyone who plays
for the rams like i hate except sorry i
take it back like kelly stafford follows
me on instagram i love her and her
husband queen yeah i love her and her
husband i just hate like the fans like
the celebrities it's like you guys like
have everything in la like can other
people in the country have one thing no
and it's like you just got a team calm
down
yeah yeah no and it's like some of us
have had teams for centuries and never
won and like you started your team
yesterday and you already won the thing
is i'm actually a rams fan now because
they won the super bowl on harry's day
of birth and that means something to me
why because it's like they were the
winners and so was i and we were all
just like having a great day so i feel a
simpatico sorry like deal with it okay
i it's so hard to separate like players
teams and then what it means for the
country because like generally i don't
really like going to la i don't like la
is a town um but like the staffords
obsessed the kids so cute high school
sweethearts like give me more like
obsessed
so let's make our super bowl predictions
i'm gonna
i'm going with the 49ers like i'm gonna
be like a good fan like i even watched
the game on sunday when i was in seattle
and they were playing seattle so i was
like in my hotel room rooting against
seattle traitor and kyle giuseppe was
like
it's nice when like the per play not to
be like so annoying it's i said the
player you know like doesn't suck you
know
yeah like of course like i'm a c-list
celebrity the players who are going to
know me stink fellas because they're
spending all their time on instagram
fellow sea listeners right so like it's
nice to have like an a-lister in my
that's why like i'm a mets fan ben is
like really good friends with pete
alonso and like could he be better i
think he's like the best baseball player
right now you know who's actually the
best baseball player right now making
headlines today who
aaron judge
tamara son tied for home runs with babe
ruth
wow really yeah i saw a headline that
he's doing things
um well
i don't really care i'm like a pete
alonso stan
rookie of the year home run derby winner
two years in a row
has his own charity and you know the
charity world is so important
okay who's going to win the super bowl i
don't know any other teams like because
you can't it has to be east versus west
no it's like afc and
nfc right because i want to wait you
want to hear how psychotic this is and
why like football is low-key unfair
there's two reasons why football is
unfair
one cause like if you go into overtime
on a football game
whoever has the ball first like whoever
it's whoever scores first yeah whoever
has the ball first like it's unfair
second why it's not fair is like all the
teams don't play each other isn't that
crazy because i was looking for like a
san francisco 49ers game for like a new
york team so i could go and like root on
my boyfriend kyle
and she was like weirdly jealous of kyle
i'm like janice why are you so obsessed
with me it's like she was a lesbian or
something
um
and they don't play each other so it's
like how can you really be the best team
if you don't play all the teams
well you would beat the teams that beat
that i know but i don't think that's
fair
okay the ball is it's giving hoax it's
giving manti teo
that's not helpful to the situation
there was a hoax involved he just wasn't
a part of it but like when you associate
his name with hoax it's not helping
we need to associate his name with hero
inspiration okay you're giving snowflake
energy like
not at all you're just like
we're
doing the exact same thing that like we
were really for sure for sure for sure
it was also um a joke so there's that
who is gonna win the super bowl why are
you asking me i'm saying the 49ers
versus
you said who's gonna win oh that's true
okay versus um
the kansas city chiefs
we had that super bowl so that and it
can happen again so it's possible yeah
um for me for me
but not for me
i was gonna win
you liked the um
is there a utah team
ah
the jazz that's basketball
the utah jazz hands they're so good this
year
no um
yeah i need to do a little more research
but like i have literally no idea what's
going on okay so like hound me and then
give no answer great
great let's dive in i trapped you
literally
to today's stories
the fast side stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
um
we've gotten our hum button fixed which
is just a great relief to everyone
everywhere it's muscle memory for me i
know i'm an athlete um our
is brought to you by visa do you ever g
do you ever dream of starting something
game changing then visa can help make it
happen maybe it's creating and selling
your own customized kicks transforming
your dorm into a plushy pop-up shop or
finally going mainstream with your side
hustle you know for us girlies it was
about starting a morning show that would
revolutionize the morning show industry
and then eventually the podcast industry
and the digital landscape for all
eternity
whatever your game-changing idea is
whether it's
a game-changing idea for new moms olivia
has a great has she told you about like
the product she wants to embed invent
for moms oh i don't know maybe i don't i
don't know if i want to say cuz like
it's actually a good idea and it doesn't
feel like it would be like a hard
prototype to build and if you have visa
behind you you can really do anything
i'm not gonna spoil it i'll ask her
first
um so if you have a game-changing
morning routine whatever you're bold
enough to try visa has the power to help
bring your game-changing idea to life
visa anyone can change the game
great thank you so much claudia our
first welcome update from the big story
of the week that broke yesterday um adam
levine and bihari prinsloo are spotted
together for the first time after affair
allegations in photos obtained by daily
mail on tuesday the singer and his
pregnant wife were seen picking up their
two children from school in montecito
levine who was all smiles sported a red
band tee and black shorts while bahati
wore a white t-shirt with her hair in a
bun the two of them were smiling and
clearly putting out the signal that all
is well over here
right because like how have they gone
without being paparazzi for years i've
literally never seen a picture of them
being paparazzi and now there's like a
big scandal and that paparazzi just
happens to capture them well and also
it's like now they're interesting to the
paparazzi so maybe like but they're
still a-list like maybe there was shame
to an interest but like
adam levine picks his kids up from
school with his wife
right it only takes one parent to pick
up a kid from school let's just be real
but they want us to know that they're
fine
we are now up to four women coming
forward with
flirty allegations allegations of
misappropriate behavior inappropriate
behavior are all the allegations just
texting or is there any physical
so far i'm just seeing messages but i
guess like the messages are easy to
prove
right he had said to someone like you're
so much more beautiful in person like
meaning they had met in person oh yeah
did you also see emily ratakowski yeah
that's our next story because okay
so station the girly who made the
initial allegations made a second video
and she was like i feel like i have like
so much to say because my first video i
was like really flustered basically like
a tabloid had emailed me that they were
running the story
and i wanted to get out in front of it
and i realized like i left a bunch of
gaps in my story
the main one being that i was told he
was separated
um
and
whether or not that's true i'm not sure
but she just kept saying in both of her
videos that she had was that she was new
to l.a
like as if that's some sort of excuse
like i
uh
thought his wife passed away like there
was like why did like the way that she
kept saying i was new to l.a like that's
not a thing it's not a different planet
no and like i don't live in la but i
know adam levine is married to bihari
prinsloo and i don't live in la and i
know that you're really not supposed to
see someone who's married it's like kind
of an unethical you know it's the
crossing of a line yeah
i mean i guess
what she might be trying to say is that
she's new to town doesn't know a lot of
people if this person takes an interest
in you
it's hard to be like oh no adam levine
i'm not interested no for sure and
that's what we were saying yesterday
it's like
both parties are responsible but we'd be
remiss if we didn't acknowledge that
there's a power imbalance when it's
someone significantly older more
powerful and more famous than you like
you're swept up in it and so it takes an
extremely strong person
to turn down a situation like that i'm
more interested in um someone was
reaching out to her gonna expose the
story and that's why she came forward
because for me it's like she came
forward with this nobody like prompted
asked whatever and she's like looking
for sympathy it feels like when she was
a mistress
right
but if she came forward because it was
going to come out then that's would
explain that well i can't imagine
i don't but that i don't want to say
like that's not true or whatever but
like it feels like she came forward
because of this most recent message
about the baby named sumner
well that's true but i also can't
imagine whatever tabloid was gonna
expose the affair would have painted her
in a worse light than she painted
herself like she just did herself no
favors in that video
yeah
yeah
like she was being
derogatory towards bahati like like she
couldn't even say her name she was
giving her like making herself out to be
the victim when she didn't really
paint a good picture in terms of details
as to why we should see it that way
right she just did herself no favors so
she might honestly she might as well
just let the tabloid do it
right so what else did she put out in
her neck in her second video any other
just that she was new to la she was
under the impression that they were
separated when she found out that that
was not true she ended it um
yeah
can i tell you how i see it yeah
i feel like
but hottie doesn't care
like i feel like sometimes when and we
see this all the time in hollywood like
if you want to be married to a rock star
the rock star does rock star tings and
that's just like uh some piece you have
to make and
maybe like i'm sure they have a good
loving relationship when it's the two of
them he's also said in interviews like
monogamy isn't natural so that has to be
like a philosophy that she subscribes to
as well
and of course it's like always
embarrassing when your extracurricular
activities are put on blast to the world
but like her going and doing school pick
up with him and like putting on smiles
is like i don't know if she thought ever
that she was in a monogamous
relationship that's a really really good
point and i like that however i think in
arrangements like that the
understanding has to be like you can do
this but you can't embarrass me like you
have to be you can't be messy and i'm
sorry like multiple instagram model
messages like that's the definition of
messy like if you want to have affairs
in hollywood and keep them low-key like
there's a way to do it there's a certain
type of girl who is like you know
built for that and girls who are
instagram models and have only fans and
like are always like chasing some sort
of fame like that's not the type of girl
you you would responsibly have an affair
with yeah so maybe she's mad at him for
the way that he went about it but i i
just don't feel like this is that
crushing to their relationship right not
the infidelity it's not like she packed
up her things we've got moving trucks
across the street no they're going to
pick their kids up from school like
i don't know that how much of this was
new information for her
no i actually love that perspective and
i'm going to choose to see it that way
because they're definitely they're like
indie cool not like other couples like i
totally see them like being okay with
one another
i mean doing it when someone's pregnant
like is a little [ __ ] up but you know
there's this couple on tick tock who has
an open relationship and i don't follow
them but their content is always being
served to me and um they talk a lot
about like how they're in an open
relationship they tried monogamy for a
few years they hated it but they do
maintain the monogamy when the woman is
pregnant and i feel like that's fair
that's fair but it's not like this is
coming out while she's pregnant
yeah i'm not i don't know how much
happened while she's pregnant trails
trails that's so true so i don't know i
just feel like celebrities they're not
like other folks and like no celebrities
they're not like us adam levine is a
bona fide rock star yeah
i just feel like
that's what rock stars do and like if
you're married to one there's some sort
of understanding especially if you're
the next day being chipper and and
saying all yeah
no you're so right and i could also see
bihari like wanting to have a boyfriend
on the side like she's
literally so cool yeah
i used to get her so confused with lily
um
aldridge
and then they're both married to rocks
to rock stars yeah lily aldridge is
married to the lead singer of kings of
leon which is like so cool
yeah
like it's funny how adam levine is a
rock star but i wouldn't say maroon 5 is
so cool
no and i wouldn't say maroon 5 is a rock
band
yeah but i'd like to speak to dana about
her girls like you but like that's not
rock right dana said that she's very
disappointed in adam levine but she's
his number one fan she'll still be going
to maroon 5 concert
you know i don't think like this takes
away from the fact that like
it's a banger you know banger season
she will
be loved
yeah
and if they're fine i'm fine like i love
when people get like so bent out of
shape about like celebrity things and
then like the celebrities like don't
[ __ ] care
yeah like emrata's making tick tocks
like i'm trying so hard not to lose my
[ __ ] like as if she's bahati right well
let's get into our next story because m
radha is weighing in on adam levine's
scandal amid her split with sebastian
bear mclearn no that's not what's
jarring about the situation like for me
why this is newsworthy is because the
tic-tac-toe responding to was made by
fellow celebrity sarah foster yeah no it
you mentioned that tick tock yesterday
where sarah foster is like
what about the women who are
cheating on
with sleeping with married men like what
about them like it's just as much their
fault like
emily ratakowski then
stitched that video with one of her own
saying um
i don't understand why we continue to
blame women for men's mistakes
especially when you're talking about 20
something year old woman dealing with
men in positions of power who are twice
their age the power dynamic is so skewed
it's ridiculous it's predatory it's
manipulative if you're the one in a
relationship you are the one who's
obligated to be loyal okay so i agree
with what emrata said like in this
particular scenario like there's totally
a power imbalance and i don't know if it
can be judged the same as like every
other infidelity but i feel like the the
statement that she made where it's like
it's on the per it's on the person who's
in the relationship to keep the
relationship like if it's not going to
be you know summoner show it's going to
be someone else who's going to [ __ ] out
them lead
and i just don't agree with that like
whatsoever like we all have a
obligation to wake up every day and not
be a piece of [ __ ] so i don't know if i
necessarily agree with that and i feel
like when you're talking about like the
other woman and like not placing any
blame on the other woman um
emratta is like
her thing is like she empowers women and
i just feel like that
that literally empowers women to be weak
like i don't agree with that statement
whatsoever and it's like the way that
emrata looks at it it's like women
aren't equal to men like they're not
smart enough or strong or strong enough
like
because they could always be you know
whisked away
and it's it's a power imbalance because
one's a man and one's a woman like she's
literally like that's literally just
saying like women are weak like women
aren't capable of making decisions for
themselves having agency and any time
like a woman makes mistakes it's because
they were placed in a situation
and i feel like thinking like that line
of thinking
it's like damaging to women like yeah
actually i can make my own decisions
like i am strong i am powerful and i
don't want special treatment because i'm
a woman like that makes me feel weak and
actually not equal to men yeah no you
need to like hold women accountable
yeah like if a woman a woman [ __ ] up i
feel like a lot of the time and like i
love this queen more than anything and
this is just like a totally random
example that's not really a good example
but like and she's finally started to
lean into the jokes about her not being
able to read leah michelle but like the
last time she commented on it she was
like well i don't know if people would
be saying that if i was a woman and if i
wasn't a woman and like that [ __ ]
line of thinking and that just line
that makes us weak i'm sorry it does
because it makes no [ __ ] sense it's
that line for me like you lose all
credibility like right you have you're
wrong you're no and you're just like
it's so [ __ ] although that's not to
say that there aren't situations where
like
someone is being treated differently in
the press or like a rumor or a
conspiracy theory because they're a
woman i don't think that that's
something that doesn't happen it happens
all the time but like when you're just
randomly pulling it out of your ass like
well i'm a woman it's like oh you have
nothing else to say
you have nothing else to say that's what
it is so i just like kind of feel like
in her quest to empower women um emratta
is depowering women honestly like i
don't the way she describes womanhood
like doesn't make me feel strong she's
like it makes me feel like i need
special care she's infantilizing yes
yeah i don't subscribe to that version
of feminism and i feel like that's like
the new wave feminism where it's like i
think like og feminism is like [ __ ] we
just want to be equal like let us have
our jobs let us do the same let us get
paid the same and it's like weirdly
taking on this like women need special
protection well that's actually not
equality
yeah
and that's my feminism one-on-one of the
job i just think emratta is immensely
projecting her situation onto this yeah
she hasn't really spoken about
that
i feel like she's using this as a vessel
to share her thoughts and clearly she's
so only mad at her ex-husband sebastian
mcclardia like and that's fine for her
and her situation who knows what he was
doing maybe there were like multiple
women she can't be busy holding all
those women accountable when it's just
like the one common denominator and
that's him
but
speak on that you know not this
situation which is which is very
different and that's also not to say
that when someone has an affair the
husband and the mistress are 50 50 to
blame like there's definitely more blame
to put on the person who's married
but we are all human beings and like we
all should do our best to be good people
and knowingly having an affair with
someone who's in a relationship like
that's not something like a great person
does
yeah and if we're always just focusing
on the other person right more wrong yes
but it takes two to tango it takes two
people to destroy a marriage it really
does or a relationship and i just don't
and i i can't stress enough how like
adam levine is majorly to blame
in this situation and this isn't even a
good example because
there is a power imbalance but i think
when you're discussing like affairs in
general i think we all just need to sit
down and watch the other woman
yeah because that film really that that
empowers women
it does but then at the end of the day
you don't blame the other woman because
in that situation the other women did
not know right they were being lied to
they weren't googling their mans right
their man wasn't famous you know yeah so
he said hey i'm a single guy i live in
connecticut oh how great i just met this
great single guy
yeah
and once they found out they joined team
woman
team woman which is that's really kind
of the lesson is that we should all
watch that film
agreed
and that's really all i have to say
so i'm just
in the future like do not treat me
special because i'm a woman i really i
don't want it
i hate that [ __ ] i hate that [ __ ] too
it's like it's embarrassing for for like
our gender like
we are just as capable and like that's
what the whole point is you know so why
are we being treated different
and insisting on different treatment
right
because we're women like no
uh well depends on the situation but
yeah of course this is like a very
nuanced conversation i'm sure people are
going to like want to kill us and it's
that's
every situation is different and should
be treated as such i don't think like
blanket statements are helpful here yeah
even though i just made about 11. but
the one where if someone like is relying
on it's because i'm a woman
i hate that [ __ ] yeah that's you ran out
of options no like you literally have
nothing else to say and i'm just going
to consider you wrong in this situation
yeah wrong can't make like your part and
just when it feels so out of left you're
dragging all women into this yeah like
leave us alone even though there are
situations where that is a true answer
i do believe
that yeah like you think like the
backlash someone is doing is like
the backlash someone is getting is like
so like
beyond
what it should be
and like other men have done this have
done the same thing and there wasn't
even remotely that much backlash like
then that makes me think
okay
so like i said it's a case-by-case
situation i don't really feel like
blanket statements are helpful
agreed even though i've made it quite a
few
are you ready for our next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by upside yes
from cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts and it really truly hurts
and that's why we started using upside
an incredible app for anyone who buys
gas groceries or times out because with
every purchase we are earning cash back
thanks to upside so you can use upside
anywhere for me i've had the most
success using at the grocery store
because all i spend my money on
consistently every day every minute of
every day is food um i've used it and it
totally works it is a no-brainer so to
get started you download the free upside
app use our promo code tmt5
to get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more next you'll claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside check
in at the business pay as usual with
your credit or debit card and then
you'll just get paid in comparison to
credit card rewards or loyalty programs
you can earn three times more cash back
with upside
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week and that's
why they have a 4.8 star rating on the
app store download the free upside app
use promo code tmt5s that's tmt is in
the morning toast number five tmt5 to
get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more that's five dollars or more in cash
back on your first purchase of 10 or
more using promo code tmt5 on the free
upside app available to download now
great thank you
our next story selena gomez is shedding
tears in my mind and me documentary
trailer she says i wouldn't change my
life so selena gomez is giving fans an
intimate look into the highs and lows of
her life since achieving stardom on
tuesday apple tv plus released the
trailer to her upcoming documentary
titled my mind and me which spans over
the past six years of her life wow in
the teaser trailer fans see the actress
on several different occasions where
she's smiling laughing and many where
she's bursting into tears she also
shared the trailer on her instagram
writing my mind and me we don't get
along sometimes and it gets hard to
breathe but i wouldn't change my life
out november 4th
i feel like this is the perfect time for
selena to be releasing a documentary you
know i love a celebrity documentary i
also love one that
doesn't feel
like you're like promoting something or
it's like a short period of time like
six years like that's enough for me to
see the whole picture and we all know
selena like went through a really dark
period a while ago and i believe six
years ago was probably like the tail end
of that and her journey like coming out
of it
so um i think it'll cover a really
interesting time in her life and i hope
we get like snippets of taylor swift
and i'm like i'm in my selena era like
i'm ready for this documentary i might
not have been ready for it two years ago
but i'm ready for it now i'm ready for
it now and we always say like i feel
like a good time for a person to make a
documentary is when it feels like they
have some answers not all the answers
but like a chapter is closed you know
there's growth we're not
you're not saying something that
literally a year from now
you'll feel differently not be true so i
feel like who she is today
yes
is
someone who i want to hear from like
what you figured some stuff out someone
who's grown and learned and like yeah
experienced tough things one lived life
like i think you know an 18 year old
with a documentary is like a grade silly
sometimes um
especially because like
it's what do you have to say what are
some 18 year olds especially artists who
are very profound but
just go live your life and then come
talk to us like don't worry about yes
right now no i agree and selena's not
really the type of celebrity who like
has really shared anything personal with
us in the last six years i feel like we
know a lot about her music and we know a
lot about rare beauty and she's like a
big mental health advocate but we don't
really know like what
she's like like i feel like she stopped
sharing that version of herself a really
long time ago yeah even like her social
media is very curated
she's not someone who's like doing
stories just like talking to the camera
while she's like
[ __ ] around yeah so i think this is a
perfect
subject matter for documentary i'm
excited to watch it so am i um
i
feel like apple tv plus is like the type
of thing you literally buy for a month
just to watch the thing that you want to
watch and then they're like struggling
yeah like everybody bought bought it for
ted lasso they binge the whole season
they turn it off they buy it again for
billy eilish documentary turn it off
they'll buy it again for this turn it
off it's like not there's not like a
steady stream of like premium content
and what's so crazy is like they have
everyone's
eyeballs you know i have to watch apple
tv ads all the time because i have a
typical tv when i turn on my apple tv
like they're showing me promotions for
shows on apple tv right and still
keep it yeah keep it
keep it i'm so good but thank you for
the offer
no i'm very kind of you genuinely
appreciative
but except for me no thank you but i
will i will subscribe for this same
subscribe i
i'm keeping an eye out for celina
recently and i just i really like what
i'm seeing so um
i'm thrilled speaking of selena i caught
up on only murders in the building oh
i'm like five episodes behind i'm not
gonna spoil anything one thing i had to
mention is that michael rappaport
playing the police detective
was so amazing he was so good
i didn't i don't even know if he's an
actor i only know him as like you know
the bravo liberty and podcaster and
uh what's the word firebrand yeah
but he was so good and so perfectly cast
and that show is so funny because every
extra every ancillary character is
someone you know cara delevingne's in it
amy schumer amy schumer tina fey like
every time someone new comes on it's
like oh
mega star yeah um
and
so they really could get anyone and i
loved that it was him he was so good so
his trade is acting all the other stuff
that you know him from is like ancillary
like he is an actor first and foremost
he was on uh a brief stint on friends
where he also played a cop that's kind
of like his thing because he's like so
new york and he talks like this and he's
from queens and brooklyn and new york
and
him playing a cop is so natural
and i think it was a great casting as
well
it made it i really enjoyed him you know
who i didn't love in it who cara
delevingne i agree i found her to be
distracting the whole time i was just
like
what are you following at all what's
going on with cara delevingne i am
it's really sad
she's been exhibiting some like erratic
behavior in public recently um and i
think people were just like chalking it
up to like her being like crazy party
girl like not really anything that
serious
um
and some footage was released like last
weekend of her outside her house like
looking and acting really um out of
sorts on the phone kicking around her
hair was all crazy margot robbie went to
her house margot robbie was photographed
leaving her house in tears yeah um i
don't know what's going on but like
justice
yeah it's not good it's not funny either
right which is why i haven't really
spoken about it there's not much to say
other than like i really hope that she
gets the help that she needs the
pictures of her like at the airport she
was like supposed to get on jay-z's
plane she's barefoot she didn't get on
like they wouldn't let her on the plane
or something uh and then she's like on
the phone and it's just
it's really sad
yeah and i feel like you know it's kind
of been like a a known thing that she's
just like a party girl who likes to have
fun like she's been photographed you
know outside her house and she had like
a bag of cocaine fall out um i don't
think anyone was ever at the point not
that like you're not supposed to be
worried about someone who does cocaine
but like it's a thing in hollywood it's
like a party thing i don't think anyone
was ever really actually like worried
about her
um now it's just to a point where like
it's overly concerning
yeah i also um she has a collab with the
kara lagerfeld brand that just came out
i followed them on instagram and like
this stuff is so cute they had a launch
party at fashion week and like she
wasn't even there
it's just
i i think it's a really bad situation i
know and i hope like the people close to
her are reaching out
yeah
yeah but anyways what's so crazy is like
everything that she does professionally
like success i think i'll be a model
today number one model i'm done with it
i want to be an actress yeah number one
actress like whatever she decides to do
professionally like she's really uh
successful at i just didn't love her in
the show because
i was like just curious about her
offline friendship with selena gomez
yeah 100
and just really quickly back to what you
said about like her just deciding to
like do things and then she excels to
the top of it i think that's in part
because like once you're selected as
like a muse of karl lagerfeld like the
world is your oyster
and she comes from like a
very wealthy aristocratic family like
yes the opportunities for her are
endless like the connections are endless
the ones that she made just growing up
then the one she made in modeling then
the one she made in acting like she can
really do whatever she wants right and i
also think that as you stated like she's
this fun party girl i think people
really like her being around her
i think she's a really big personality i
think so too i think she has like that
energy that like
people just want to be around like she's
charismatic she's funny she must be like
a great people connector like yeah she's
a good like she's a girl you want to be
friends with yeah and i just really i'm
wishing her well
yes same
uh
and so selena gomez's documentary check
it out november 4th two days before my
birthday uh
what a day
what a day 30th of birthday
it was his 50th birthday
so crazy what are you going to get me
i have not even thought about it i
didn't even get an anniversary gift last
week yeah but like i'm easier to shop
for them ben
yeah no because like for you um i just
need to take out a mortgage and then
i'll be able to find something that you
like no it's the thought that counts
okay cool you know it's the thought that
counts for me yeah no but and for me
like this you just don't forget about it
though for me the thought is the hardest
part
i'd rather just throw money at the
problem i'd rather take out a mortgage
yeah no i'll have to think about
something if anyone has any good ideas
message me oh and i was just thinking
what did i get you for your birthday i
really went all out so what did i get i
don't forget wait hold on
oh yeah you did really go all out
so i'm earning some goodwill points yeah
yeah yeah
yikes
okay ready for our next story well i am
traveling down with theo for your 30th
birthday so like that's partially my
gift
it helps it's all to the good it's all
to the good
are you ready for our next story yes
anna de armas went to marilyn monroe's
grave to ask permission to film blonde
anna de armas revealed she and the crew
behind her upcoming movie blonde visited
marilyn monroe's grave in la and asked
her permission to film her life story
she said in an interview quote we got
this big card and everyone in the crew
wrote a message to her then we went to
the cemetery and put it on her grave we
were asking for permission in a way
everyone felt a huge responsibility and
we were very aware of the side of the
story we were going to tell the story of
norma jean the person behind the
character marilyn monroe who was she
really
also
it's been reported that there was a
supernatural vibe on the set
of the movie they said that they
believed monroe's ghosts would also
throw things off the wall sometimes and
get mad if she didn't like something
i quote truly believe that she was very
close to us she was with us
the director agreed and said it
definitely took on elements of being
like a seance
[Laughter]
let's start with the first part
they asked permission
to the grave of marilyn to do this movie
like for me this is what i just
can't deal people in hollywood are so
not okay they're so self-important like
honestly i really cannot even dignify
this story with comment seriously my
official comment is no comment like for
real seriously okay leave darling alone
here's what i want to ask you like do
you think the ghost of marilyn monroe
was on the set letting that i do no i
really do
i feel like this is the sort of thing
that they're saying to get buzz around
the movie oh my god marilyn's go she was
there gotta see it
like i'm just
i'm just picturing the trolley of actors
camera operators directors producers pas
craft services the trolley pulling up to
this old cemetery
and then play a one card big hollywood
budget you can even bring flowers just
one [ __ ] card
placing it and then they're being like
oh we feel her this is literally like
hollywood delusion i can't with these
people
people are and this is just like a
general statement i think on the status
of society people are not okay yeah
deeply unwell
and to think that we want to hear this
okay maybe like if
if i may like maybe you're playing the
most iconic really woman
in the last century
it's a
overwhelming thing and you want to make
sure you're doing her justice so maybe
personally you're like praying to the
ghost of maryland like whatever
making sure like she's okay with
everything that you're doing but to
think that we want to hear about it and
like we think that this is normal and to
think that you're the first and only
movie to ever be made about marilyn
monroe like this isn't like the official
they're like they're trying to say like
marilyn sanctioned this movie right no
it's lit this is like pr goblins like i
don't like this it's ghost pr yeah it's
using like a sorcery for press
yeah
and i'm not buying it and this is making
me think low of everyone involved
agreed
and now i'm thinking that 14-minute
standing ovation was just a hoax too
maybe it was maryland getting everyone
up out of their seats
[Applause]
spooky
it is quite spooky though don't you
think no i'm not spooked at all like in
fact i've never been more calm but maybe
it was they were getting confused maybe
it was just the ghost of snitches past
that has happened to me before where i
think it's marilyn monroe but it's just
the ghost of sneeja's past
she has been known to go to movie sets
and throw things off walls
spooky season is almost upon us we have
got to start thinking about what we're
going to do for toast to win 2022. i
presented an idea that's a decent backup
idea it's a decent it's a great backup
but i do think we can do something
slightly more relevant yeah no i think
so too uh we'll just have to put our
thinking caps on i already know what my
personal costume is going to be i've
started ordering some things for are you
going to go
uh trick-or-treating in the neighborhood
i think so but also you know like to get
dressed and take pictures and yeah yeah
all that yeah um and all that jazz
so if you're like want to just dress
with my family i think we could come up
with a part for you well i am gonna be
at your house for about a week for toast
to wean we're gonna be together and then
your birthday is the next weekend so i'm
just going to stay with you for that
week so make sure my make sure my
quarters have been properly prepared i
will and if you want to send any
costumes down here yeah
oh so i guess i'll be able to go
trick-or-treating in the name with you
yeah oh that's
cute
i'm so ready for halloween like the way
i [ __ ] die for halloween candy
i know and i know it's available year
round it does not taste the same no and
it's like why would you have candy year
round and don't get me wrong like being
in the city for halloween like it sucks
like there's really no like
trick-or-treating but the fact that
every residential or corporate building
you walk into like does have a big bowl
of candy in the lobby like that is worth
its weight in gold no and in my building
like they oh like they put that bowl out
early they leave it till late like and i
don't know if i was the only one
continuing to eat all the candy but i
didn't feel like i missed out because i
lived in new york like i always lived in
a building that respected the art of
halloween my current building does not
respect the bowl and i think the last
two years i've said i'm gonna purchase a
bowl and just like be the one
responsible and i never remember but i'm
doing it this year yeah just go on
amazon like buy it now it'll be ready
what if you dress but my building is
like so [ __ ] like fancy and like
they're gonna be like this bowl is not
from pottery barn like
literally the i walked out of my
apartment last night to
uh
pick up my dinner and i saw the mayor of
new york
and what'd you say and i gave him a
smile and then he turned around and i
went like this
that's me like i'm a two-faced [ __ ]
like social climbing star [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's why me and the mayor get
along because he and i have that in
common
totally that like literally the mayor
like that is exactly what i would do
like i can't even blame him for like
being like a party boy like he's not
interested in city tings no who the [ __ ]
would be look around interested in the
job interested in the celebrities is he
the greatest mayor we've ever had no is
he the most relatable
yes
i get it eric i do i really do like i
would also want to go to all these
members clubs like
the new members club amman have you
heard of it no
it's like the amount hotels they now are
membership clubs it's actually uh
sickening i've walked past it it smells
amazing the membership
the membership fee is a lowly
it's i don't know maybe 20 25 grand you
got to put up
500 grand
that you get back when somebody buys
your membership back
but it's like collateral because i guess
like maybe a bunch of people can afford
25 grand but not that many people can
afford 500 grand okay and what does this
club get you
it's a membership club i think they have
like spa gym restaurant bar and then i
think you also get like preferred
treatment premium vip treatment if you
stay at any of the aman properties like
the amangiri i'm on in turks and caicos
wait 500 000 to get like an upgrade a
room upgrade like no literally you
should be getting free like that should
cover the rooms like no i know
that's insane i know but like
you will catch me walking past it i've
actually walked past it many times um
like i'm gonna sneak in like i want to
go
wow
if i could just post it i'll put
together a gofundme
for the 500 grand and everyone gets paid
back when i lose my membership
eventually for talking about it 100
first rule of amman don't talk about
amon first role of all these clubs and
it's like
yeah just let us talk about it no
totally it's totally are you ready for
our fifth and final story the final
story
in unlikely real housewives news jon
hamm is calling out erica jane over her
earrings drama quote they were never
yours this is crazy housewives fan jon
hamm called out erica jane for her
hesitation to give back the 750 000
diamond earrings her estranged husband
tom gifted her with allegedly stolen
settlement funds he said you just want
to shake her and go honey they were
never yours give them back nothing
questioned whether the earrings are
valued at 750 000 or 1.3 million but he
reaffirmed that she should that's a fair
question is it 750 each no so they were
originally valued at 750 purchased back
in 2007 however their worth has since
increased plus inflation right right
they're probably over a million dollars
now yeah it just can't feel good like
obviously bravo fans are [ __ ] brutal
they'll eat you alive but like you get
used to it to have two a-listers
back-to-back
coming at you calling you evil like
that's rough
yeah i can't believe jon hamm watches
housewives
i mean i guess like when you're so
famous like you really don't work that
much you know
you have a lot of free time also jon
hamm it's confusing because he was don
draper who's the most serious man alive
but like jon hamm is like a goof
uh do you remember his character in 30
rock
yeah and this is boy in um kimmy schmidt
he's a reverend yeah oh my god obviously
him and dean if i have like a great
relationship
yeah
but he's just like a goofball and it's
always disarming when you find it out
because he's don draper no that's such a
good point
and that's you know what he's a good
actor
i would agree
and he's very handsome
i would agree and he's got a big dick
too and he's funny
he's smart funny smart big dick like
seriously is he single
let's look do you ever remember that
picture of him in the gray sweatpants
people were shook
i'll go get that third arm
i'm not okay jon hamm
has a girlfriend
of course he does oh i'm sorry you don't
have a dick that big with no girlfriend
yeah and then his john hamm
gray sweatpants sweatpants
did it come up in the google like no it
didn't okay wait images
or maybe just google john hand penis
maybe he wasn't wearing sweatpants yeah
because he's wearing like cargos
yeah there was like one picture where
his dick was swinging
penis takes its own route for a walk
gawker
that's funny that is funny
you okay
that's [ __ ] funny
so that's what you needed to know about
jon hamm today
and it's just funny that he has a big
dick and his name is jon hamm like
that's literally the name of someone
with a big dick john hamm
yeah also
beverly hills is on tonight it's
shit's going down episode this is the
the prince was promised you know post
aspen blowout i've seen the clips that
are emerging i still believe in a world
where like lisa arena is wants to see
kathy go down and is it exaggerating
but i'll keep him an open mind
yeah no i won't keep an open mind i
don't even care what i see i'm team cafe
like yeah no i don't care what i see i'm
team kathy but um i'll hear
i'll hear about it
um speaking of hearing about things we
have your toasters our advice segment
which i just wanted to make a quick
announcement before we dive in we're
running low on submissions so if you
haven't uh written in yet now's the this
is the chance dear toasters at gmail.com
try and keep it a little brief like we
can't really read anything that long um
just need to know information we'll
totally keep it anonymous you can write
in about anything deartoasters gmail.com
the same goes for unburden yourselves
unburden yourselves at gmail.com do you
think that people are not writing in as
much because like we've solved all the
world's problems right there's no crime
before dinner time because all the crime
has been resolved and i want my dinner
now
i really that was me last night i
couldn't even get out of my building
there was like because u n week there
was like police everywhere i said sir i
have to go get my dinner i want it now
and he's like ma'am why are you singing
in the middle of the street
so dear toasters is brought to you by
modern fertility
knowledge is power and when you know
more you can make better decisions for
your body your health and your future
there aren't many decisions bigger than
having a kid but for many women their
fertility is a big question mark and
that's why modern fertility was created
an easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in mail it in with
a prepaid label you'll get personalized
results within 10 days you'll get
insights into your hormone levels your
ovarian reserve other or important
fertility factors the results are going
to go deep into what every hormone means
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
and you guys know if you want to do
traditional testing at the doctor it can
cost over 600
but modern fertility gets you the same
information at a fraction of the cost
plus if you go to modernfertility.com
toast 30 you can get 30 off your test
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 30 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast
it's a limited time offer for 30 off
which means your test will cost you just
169
instead of the hundreds or even
thousands it could cost at the doctor's
office get 30 off your fertility test
when you go to modern fertility.com
toast 3-0 modern fertility dot com slash
toast three zero
all right first up hello jax claude
brass and straz
monsters and mrs boys long time listener
ever since claude has been posting from
the bath
anyways i need some advice on a new
relationship i'm dating a man who's 10
years older than me i'm in my 20s he's
in his 40s but it's not the age
difference that's an issue for me as we
are really simpatico and are of equal
maturity he's definitely he's by
definition a pea job he does things like
randomly bring me coffee in the morning
brings me to work early in the morning
before he has to be up he even brings
treats over for my cat we have a lot of
similar interests and we get along great
and he recently told me that he's in
love with me
my only concern is that he's been
married not once but twice before he's
been very transparent with me about why
both marriages ended and what went wrong
and he seems to have really grown from
it the first marriage he was very young
he didn't choose someone he was
compatible with and they were both very
unhappy the second he ended up being
with someone who needed a lot of support
and looking after and ultimately ended
with her cheating on him my question is
do you think this is a recipe for
disaster i give in the past or should i
give this p job a chance sincerely a
trepidatious toaster
i don't think so i think at 40 something
like
that tracks right to me it would be a
bigger red flag if he's 40 something had
never been never he'd um if he had only
the one young marriage that's still like
almost 15 years of him having been
single like this is a man who
wants to find love like and he's not
going to stop until he does okay he
struck out twice like but he's back up
at the plate i respect it it shows
perseverance and strength yeah i don't
yeah
i think that that's
just
what you get when like someone is older
they've lived and that's right
i also think that like both the
marriages he described like those that
type of [ __ ] does happen like you get
married really young and like a lot of
times that doesn't work out you know you
end up really unhappy because you grow
and evolve so that totally sounds like
something that could have happened and
then literally the next [ __ ] cheated on
him like
it sounds like he's really just trying
his best
yeah it sounds like he is trying his
best and just because he's divorced like
it's i don't think that's a red flag no
and by the way you're 100 right like it
would be cause for concern if like he'd
been you know dating for 20 years and
never once even got married like that's
that's more concerning than being
married twice it sounds like he's really
just like a a hopeless romantic yeah no
if you're gonna be with an older person
like they have history and
yeah i wouldn't let it bother you i
wouldn't let it bother you either also i
mean you never know what actually
happened there's two sides to everything
right right um
but at the end of the day we can agree
that they weren't compatible matches
perhaps you guys are compatible and like
i think that's fine and also you get all
the perks of a mature man he brings your
cat treats he's softball he gets up
early in the morning and drives you to
work and there's you know
pros and cons to
you also get the history
so true i think it's fine i'm not
worried
i'm not worried at all everything sounds
great kosher but it's a fair question
yeah and i'm sure like it's maybe not
what you saw for yourself right right
being the third wife
but write a book about it the third wife
be a bestseller
take your power back take your power
back
jackson claude help
please keep this anonymous for my own
well-being lol but my mother-in-law is
obsessed with my partner's exes to give
you some context my boyfriend and i live
together and have a two-year-old
daughter but my mother-in-law always
comments posts pics loves [ __ ]
likes pics and loves [ __ ] that my
boyfriend's exes post on social media am
i being dramatic or is it normal for me
to think this is [ __ ] weird do i say
something to her do i make him say
something it feels like a slap in the
face that i'm constantly competing for
her approval with his exes sincerely a
salty toaster it's weird don't let
anyone think any different it's weird
and it's inappropriate you have a child
with this man and you shouldn't say
anything because like there's no
reason for like
you to get involved but your man needs
to say something like for real yeah also
if it maybe if it was just like one x
who she personally connected with right
whatever some people
connect but that she's like more
interested in exes than his present
relationship it's like what do you need
to break up with him for her to like you
right you should say that to your man
yeah this is on your man to communicate
first of all like first and foremost and
you know what just
just know that this is a thing about the
mother-in-law's character like she's
never really gonna truly fully support
you so don't think for one second that
she's a friend and someone you could
trust like i wouldn't ever confide in
her she sounds like a honestly a
vindictive wench
yeah like you this is a great kid yeah
and you're commenting on some ex's
facebook posts like they don't want to
be your friend
no it's [ __ ] i i bet the exes think
it's weird too everyone thinks this
woman's a freak and your man needs to
put her in her place immediately if not
sooner
she's like
she's honestly slandering the family
name by acting like a public wench it's
when she behavior and it must be stopped
and it's just
the when she behavior must come to an
end
but third and final oh my god i can't
talk today dear jack's claude rise and
stress brass and shots and bats and
shots and messengers
long time listener first time writer and
let's cut to the chase i flew across the
country to go to my fiance friend my
fiance's friend's wedding margot the
night before the wedding margot got a
little wine drunk and she pulled my
fiancee maverick aside and confessed
that she was she was marrying him
instead of her fiance she went through
the wedding but i'm still feeling
uncomfortable about the situation i'm
getting married next month to maverick
and this girl is invited she has been
friends with maverick for 10 plus years
i feel uncomfortable bringing it up
again or approaching her about the
situation do i say anything or uninvite
her from the wedding from a conflicted
toaster well i want to know how you
found out about this i'm going to assume
that your man told you which means you
have a good man on your hands
and you really don't have anything to
worry about because if he had even like
the smallest
inkling of love for her he never would
have told you
yeah this is messed up but i'm just like
trying to put myself like in the
situation to see what i would do
and it just like would depend on her
like what she looks like is she a threat
100
is she just like very sad no by the way
i love where your head is at um and not
not that we should be judging people by
how they look or like how they actually
look it's a whole package it's you know
why is she this like confident vibrant
person who people just want to be around
who like really could steal your man
steal your man who could steal even
there's there are women out there who
could steal
the pope from the church like
even the most committed faithful man
like there are women who are so
charismatic confident
stunning can do things with their
[ __ ] like there are women out there
that can steal even the most faithful
men yeah
but then there are also just like some
sad sex out there who pose absolutely no
threat to your relationship and have
been in love with the same man since you
know 10 years ago and we should you know
we should invite them to the wedding
maybe they'll meet someone else like we
feel bad married now oh right
so i think you just need to assess the
threat level like not
use your better judgment
on what type of threat this girly
possesses for real yeah because if if
it's not a threat just whatever she had
like a sad bad night and it's not it
doesn't matter and think about how
difficult if she's a sad sack think
about how difficult the night will be
for her if she gets uninvited like
yeah you couldn't do that that's kicking
someone while they're down if she is
that viper
of a woman
keep her far far away
and you have a very good reason like i
think your your fiance is not
unreasonable to reach out to her and say
vixen
um you give in the conversation we had
at your wedding i don't think it would
be appropriate for you to be at the
wedding i love you as a friend and i
only want the best for you um get the
[ __ ] out of my wedding but uh please
don't show up yeah
assess the threat that's amazing advice
and that's what you 100 should be and
that's like the real honest truth you
know yeah if you like if you're writing
into us you're not looking for you know
hallmark cards we're going to tell you
the truth yeah and the truth is that
some women are threatening and some
women are not
and you have to protect your home
seriously like you're building a life
with this man
oh man we're being like so sarah foster
because it's like it's on the mat not to
be with the vixen
no
everything comes full circle no but
here's the thing like you have
information knowledge is power if you
choose to do nothing about it
like knows what could happen next that's
on you
yeah not that i'm blaming you if
anything happens but like you know
everyone has a role to play in the
creation in their own lives it's so true
yeah thank you to everyone who was
vulnerable with us i actually think we
were quite helpful to all three like
that was some good sound advice and
these were manageable situations and
just know like if you're gonna write in
like you're not gonna get like some new
image like buzzword advice you're gonna
get advice from like your
97 year old grandma who grew up in a
shuttle in portland and portland in
poland
yeah and
it's
it's around this long for a reason yeah
like there's truth and it's harsh but it
needs to be said yeah just like
everything that we said here today
needed to be said because that's the
morning toast for you
oh just a little um quick content recap
i finished carrie soto
four stars taylor jenkins reed she does
it again like she's just such a pleasant
author to read oh maybe i'll read it
yeah it just it went by so quickly and
it didn't change my life or anything but
it was just good
carrie soto is she a character from a
previous book that i need to read
no so that's what she always does like
each of her books like in evelyn hugo
evelyn hugo marries mick riva right
mcleiba is malibu rising mick riva is
the father of the main characters in
malibu rising in malibu rising
uh the main character nina at one point
is married to a tennis player named
brandon who has an affair with carrie
soto got it so she it's always like an
ancillary character i like that book
before you don't need to read the book
um
prior no not at all but like she creates
her own world like in this book harry
soto like she was on the plane reading
an unauthorized biography of daisy jones
and vi like she self references all the
time at school that is cool
um
all right well thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast-paced stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public video i have
ready to cast box all the places baby
listen to the podcast my number one
joseph review about a beautiful song and
smart we are hope you guys have an
enclave
wednesday don't forget to help someone
you love and we'll see you tomorrow